hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and it's time to
reveal the shocking truth about the
single biggest and most important
mystery in all of One Piece when you
really think about it it all started
with the void Century Joy boy the
poneoglyphs laughtail the ancient
weapons the one-piece treasure the
origins of the world government it all
dates back to the void Century if we can
figure out what really happened during
this time which has been deliberately
erased from history then everything else
will fall into place all the other
mysteries in one piece will be resolved
and I believe that I finally have the
answer I think I know what started
everything what inspired everything and
how it all went down so let's get into
it you guys know the drill if you enjoy
our one piece content and you want us to
keep it going leave a quick like and
comment it only takes a second but it
really helps with that add YouTube
algorithm and of course if you haven't
subscribed yet do me a favor and make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification Bell to turn on
all notifications finally this video
will contain One Piece manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned now I've always been a big
fan of History including ancient history
and I've been studying it for fun ever
since I was a kid like yes seriously I
would willingly read books and watch
documentaries about ancient history when
I was in like Elementary School most
people probably think that's really
extremely nerdy and it is but it can
also be very useful as I'm about to
explain it all started with chapter 1040
where we got confirmation that zunesha
the giant elephant who carries Zoe on
his back was in fact a companion of Joy
boy before this moment we knew that
zunesha was being punished for some
grave crime that he he committed 800
years ago so during the void Century but
we didn't actually have a direct
connection between him and joyboy there
were many fan theories about it of
course but once this connection was
confirmed the gears in my head slowly
started turning the connection between
Joy boy and zunesha and the presumption
that the two of them actively fought
against the alliance that would
eventually become the world government
800 years ago reminded me of the
carthaginian general Hannibal Hannibal
is considered to be one of the greatest
Generals in history and he is famous for
using war elephants in battle he is also
known as perhaps the single greatest
enemy of ancient Rome and he led a famed
invasion of Italy during which he
crossed the Alps with an entire Army
including war elephants Rome waged
several Wars with Hannibal's homeland of
Carthage between 264 BC and 105 46 BC so
for just over a century and these wars
are known as the Punic Wars the more I
looked into the Punic Wars the more I
realized that this Century of conflict
between Roman Carthage was the direct
inspiration for the void Century in one
piece so examining what really happened
in these wars will in fact reveal what
happened during the void century and if
you think I'm reaching with this
comparison just stick around a little
bit longer I promise you won't regret it
I am excited to reveal everything I've
discovered and trust me this is big okay
so Carthage was an Empire based in
Northern Africa that basically
controlled the Western Mediterranean at
the height of its power as carthage's
power and influence expanded they
eventually came into conflict with an
also expanding role Rome was technically
a republic at the time but they were
already engaging in Imperial expansion
the 100 year long series of conflicts
between these two Powers finally ended
when Rome decided to completely destroy
Carthage after laying Siege to their
capital city which was located in
modern-day Tunisia Carthage eventually
fell to the Romans the Romans then
either killed or sold into slavery
practically everyone who survived and if
that wasn't bad enough the Romans went a
step further they systematically burned
everything in the city and they even
demolished all of the buildings and
major structures that were there some
have said that the Romans went so far as
to Salt the soil in and around Carthage
so that no crops would grow there after
the fall of Carthage all of its
territories were incorporated into the
Roman Empire but why would the Romans go
so far in their desire to destroy
Carthage why would they bother spending
so much time in Manpower leveling in
higher buildings when they could have
just occupied Carthage and turned it
into a Roman city the answer may sound
familiar the Romans wanted to make the
entire carthaginian civilization
disappear they wanted to effectively
erase Carthage from history even though
Carthage played a major role in the
history of Europe and Northern Africa
for about 800 years it was completely
annihilated and erased from history
after a century-long conflict with Rome
and the plan worked because of the
Romans managed to destroy so much of
carthage's books and libraries and even
buildings and statues we know very
little about Carthage today compared to
many other ancient civilizations who
existed around the Mediterranean such as
the Greeks Romans and Egyptians and what
we do know about Carthage often comes
from Roman sources which are clearly
biased and this is exactly what the
Romans wanted they wanted to erase the
legacy of Carthage from the pages of
History and they wanted to completely
control the narrative in terms of how
all future civilizations would look back
at Carthage the history of the Punic
Wars that we know today was written by
the winners the Romans and the immense
influence that Carthage had on the
development of the ancient Mediterranean
world has been nearly forgotten it is
much much harder to find well-preserved
carthaginian ruins and artifacts than
Greek and Roman ones and the artifacts
that do remain tend to be ones that
would have required a lot of time and
effort to actually destroy for example
we can still find large Stone pillars
with words and symbols carved into them
like this one which features azunesha at
the bottom I mean which features an
elephant at the bottom I'm sure you guys
know exactly what I'm getting at what we
have left of Carthage are basically our
world's version of pomegriffs so to me
it's clear that the void Century in one
piece is heavily inspired by the 100
year old conflict between between Rome
and Carthage Carthage is the ancient
Kingdom which was defeated and then
intentionally and methodically erased
from history and ancient Rome is the
world government which started expanding
rapidly during this period conquering
new lands and incorporating new tribes
and kingdoms until they became the
greatest Empire of the ancient world an
Empire which at its height controlled
most of Europe most of the Middle East
including Egypt and the entire Coastline
of North Africa by the way I'm curious
how many of you guys who are not history
Buffs ever even heard of Carthage let me
know down in the comments below how well
did the Romans succeed in erasing
Carthage from history now let's talk
about Hannibal Barca carthage's greatest
General and the man who nearly defeated
Rome during the Second Punic War I
believe that Hannibal was the
inspiration for joyboy and I think that
studying Hannibal's failed quest of Rome
can tell us a lot about what really
happened during the void Century in one
piece Hannibal was a brilliant General
and he is widely regarded as one of the
best Generals in the history of the
world right up there with Alexander the
Great Julius Caesar and Napoleon
Bonaparte Hannibal was known for being
kind to his man and to the animals he
used in battle which included horses and
elephants during the Second Punic War
which took place between about 218 and
201 BC Hannibal took the battle right to
Rome's doorstep by invading Italy proper
and waging a devastating campaign in
Rome's front yard this campaign lasted
for about 16 years and Hannibal was
extremely successful because he was able
to convince other tribes and cities that
Rome had subjected earlier to rebel
against Rome and join him this includes
the Gauls the ligurians and others even
though Hannibal was a complete stranger
to these people and they knew the Romans
well they decided to follow Hannibal
because they wanted Liber operation from
Roman oppression so for them Hannibal
was a liberator and they followed him
into battle one of Hannibal's best known
tactics was using war elephants
elephants would be mounted by various
warriors including archers and the
immense size of the elephants would be
used to break through the ranks of the
enemy during deadly offensive charges
the Romans and Europeans in general were
not accustomed to even seeing elephants
let alone facing them down in battle so
Hannibal's use of such gigantic and
Powerful creatures had a strong
psychological effect on the enemy
Hannibal actually came extremely close
to conquering Rome and changing history
forever but the Romans were crafty and
they played Cat and Mouse with
Hannibal's Army throughout the Italian
Countryside this denied Hannibal the
opportunity to score a decisive Victory
and conquered the city of Rome itself
because he wanted to face the Roman army
out in the open and he didn't want to
risk his troops by attacking a heavily
fortified major city like Rome Hannibal
kept at it for about 6 15 years but then
back in North Africa the Roman armies
attacked the carthaginian capital of
Carthage itself and this eventually
forced Hannibal to withdraw his troops
from Italy in order to defend his
Capital City during this crucial
campaign back in Hannibal's carthaginian
Homeland the Roman general Scipio
Africanus was able to make a deal with a
portion of Hannibal's Army the numidian
Cavalry to switch sides in exchange for
money Hannibal was ultimately defeated
by the Romans at the Battle of Zama in
202 BC now of course there was a lot of
side switching going on during the Punic
Wars as different kingdoms and tribes
switched allegiances from Rome to
Carthage and vice versa but this
betrayal by the numidian Cavalry at a
critical turning point in the war really
made me think of the nefertari family
there's always been something off about
the fact that the nefertari joined the
world government as one of the 20
founding families but they were the only
family that refused to move to marijua
on top of of that they seemingly kept an
important panaglyph hidden from the
world government and they may have a
special connection to the ancient weapon
pluton which is believed to be somewhere
in alabasta I wonder if the nefertari
were originally fighting on the side of
Joy boy and the ancient Kingdom but then
they decided to switch sides when it
became clear that the ancient Kingdom
couldn't win like maybe they switched
sides to save themselves and their
Kingdom from complete destruction but
there's also another possibility which
is that they didn't actually betray Joy
boy what if joyboy also knew that defeat
was inevitable and he actually told the
nefertari to pretend to betray him so
that they can infiltrate the world
government from within they could then
set the stage for the next big war for
the dawn of the World by protecting
certain pornoglyphs and pluton itself
until Joy boy finally returned now of
course the nefertari couldn't do any of
this if they had moved to marijua but by
choosing to stay in Alabaster they were
able to remain a part of the world
government while also helping to set the
stage for joyboy's return the current
generation of the nefertari family
including king cobra and Vivi may not
even know the truth about this at least
not yet but the truth could be revealed
to them at an important moment in the
future I do believe that at some point
during the void Century joyboy came to
realize that he was bound to lose and
that is why he left that apology on
Fishman Island he knew that this time
around he would not win but he also knew
that he would one day return and so he
made preparations for that return after
his defeat at the Battle of Zama
Hannibal survived and was pressured into
retirement and then eventually he was
pushed into Exile due to Roman military
pressure and internal political pressure
within Carthage but even then Hannibal
refused to give up he continued to fight
against the Romans by traveling to
kingdoms that had not yet been conquered
by them and then advising those kingdoms
how to fight the Romans after the Romans
dispatched a large group of soldiers to
hunt him down Hannibal was eventually
cornered he chose to take his own life
rather than be taken Alive by the Romans
Carthage continued to exist for about
four decades after that although they
were much weaker than they were before
and they were forced to pay reparations
to the Romans when Carthage started to
recover from the Second Punic War and
when it began to reassert its
independence the Romans launched the
third Punic War at the end of which they
completely annihilated Carthage and
practically erased it from history in
the aftermath carthage's territories
were completely absorbed by Rome and
what was once Carthage just became one
part of the vast Roman Empire when we
finally learned the truth about the void
Century in one piece I am willing to bet
that it will be very similar to the
events of the Punic Wars which as I
mentioned earlier took place over the
course of about 118 years just like
Hannibal Joy boy will likely turn out to
be a charismatic leader who tried to
liberate the oppressed and stop the rise
of the world government much like
Hannibal tried to stop the expansion of
Rome Joy boy recruited a bunch of
diverse peoples and kingdoms to his
cause including Giants fishmen giant
elephants like zunesha and so on zunesha
was definitely part of joyboy's Army and
if the original droidboy was a giant or
if he used the Nika fruit to gigantify
himself he could have even ridden a top
of zunesha in battle Like a carthaginian
Warrior riding atop of one of their war
elephants now to be clear in the world
of One Piece Joy boy has been portrayed
as an altruistic Liberator who wanted to
free the slaves and discrimination
between the races and overthrow the kind
of tyranny and Injustice that
characterizes the world government in
the real world things are a bit more
complicated the carthaginians and Romans
were both major Powers competing for
Supremacy over the Mediterranean so we
can't think of Hannibal as just like a
really nice guy who wanted to free the
world from the evil Romans Hannibal was
fighting for the strength and Glory of
Carthage not for some abstract ideals of
freedom and justice and of course the
Romans also thought that they were the
good guys and that they were fighting
for justice we can assume that just like
Hannibal Joy boy came very close to
winning the war and this really scared
those royal families who eventually
decided to form the world government if
we look at our own world as an example
the absolute monarchies which were so
prevalent a few hundred years ago relied
heavily on things like serfdom and
slavery to survive they exploited the
vast majority of people within their
kingdoms for the benefit of a very small
ruling Elite Class of Nobles and
Aristocrats so someone who was promising
freedom and equality for all people and
races would have presented an
existential threat to these royal
families as a result they would stop at
nothing to take someone like that down
because droyboy's Victory would have
meant the complete collapse of their
entire way of life so no wonder they
decided to completely erase the ancient
Kingdom from the pages of History just
like Rome tried to erase Carthage
joyboy's dangerous idea us about freedom
and equality had to be completely erased
from the pages of history in order to
preserve the world government's very
existence but if he came so close to
winning why did Joy boy ultimately lose
my guess is that just like with Hannibal
betrayal played an important part in it
it could be betrayal by the nefertari
family or by someone else altogether and
it is likely that the mysterious imusama
played an important role in joyboy's
Ultimate downfall I realized that this
would mean that imusama is practically
Immortal but I do think that something
along those lines will turn out to be
true imusama sits on the empty throne
and that is not something that just
anyone would be able to do I find it
hard to believe that if someone who sits
on the empty Throne happened to die that
the gorosei would just allow someone
else to assume absolute authority over
them in my opinion it's more likely that
the same person has been sitting on the
empty throne for 800 years I could be
wrong but since we already know that
immortality is possible within the world
of One Piece such as through the op up
fruit or perhaps even through turning
someone into a cyborg imusama being an
immortal ruler who actually took part in
the war 800 years ago is a strong
possibility and if imusama really turns
out to be immortal then in our Punic War
comparison imusama symbolizes Rome
itself Rome is known as the Eternal City
it has been around for thousands of
years and the ancient Romans believe
that no matter how much time passes and
how many empires rise and fall Rome
itself will go on forever countless
different eras and generations came and
went but imusama remains as the firm and
steady hand behind the world government
imusama knows the truth about the void
century and when anyone gets too close
to shining a light on that truth imusama
decides to extinguish that light from
history as the victor of the ancient war
imusama writes history in the way that
he or she sees fit just like the Romans
wrote the history of the Punic Wars in a
way that made them look Noble and
civilized while making the carthaginians
appear to be cruel and barbaric some
historians believe that the Romans
invented stories about Carthage doing
horrible things like human sacrifices
just to make themselves look better by
comparison however whether or not the
carthaginians really engaged in such
practices remains a matter of debate
among historians again there is very
little that we actually know about them
which is exactly what the Romans
intended but even if yumusama is the
immortal ruler of the world government
in the present time what role did this
person play during the void century was
he or she someone who actually fought
against Joy boy meaning that emu must
also have absolutely incredible Powers
after all the original joyboy had the
overpowered Nika fruit so could emu also
have a Godly Zone devil fruit or maybe
some other absolutely broken power or
could it be that emu actually fought
alongside Joy boy but then betrayed him
in exchange for power and immortality
this is just my personal hunch by the
way but I've always had the feeling that
imusama would turn out to be a woman emu
just strikes me as an evil queen type
character kind of like Maleficent from
Sleeping Beauty if that does turn out to
be the case I wonder if there will be
some sort of forbidden love or
unrequited love element to her
relationship with the original Joy boy
whatever the connection is I do think
that there will be an important link
between joyboy and emu and that link
will play a major role in the final arcs
of the story as Luffy the New Joy boy
takes on the world government once and
for all I am convinced that the events
of the Void Century will closely
parallel the Punic Wars and the fate of
joyboy and the ancient Kingdom will
parallel the fate of Hannibal and
Carthage in the real world Hannibal
never returned with the help of a
legendary devil fruit and Carthage was
never resurrected instead Rome went on
to dominate Europe Northern Africa and
the Middle East for centuries but the
Roman Empire did collapse eventually and
I'm sure that the world government is
going to collapse as well that said the
fall of the Roman Empire is a massive
subject on its own and if I talk about
it it will have to be in a different
video if you guys would like to see me
make a video about how the fall of Rome
could predict the ending of One Piece
leave a like And subscribe it's a quick
easy and completely free way of directly
supporting the channel what do you guys
think happened during the void century
and do you agree with me that the events
of the Void Century are likely inspired
by the Punic Wars let me know down below
and don't forget to comment who you
think imusama really is and what his or
her role may have been during the void
Century as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see ya
Space Cowboys